all right so tonight the Trump
administration draws a line in the sand
when it comes to liberal States aiding
and abetting criminal illegal immigrants
that pose a significant threat to you
the American people the Attorney General
jeff Sessions he used a news conference
today to officially announce that the
Trump administration is suing California
over their sanctuary state policies that
shield these illegal immigrants that
commit crimes sessions did not hold back
let's take a look a refusal to apprehend
and deport those especially the criminal
element of effectively rejects all
immigration law it's a rejection of law
and it creates an open borders system
it's the only way it can be described in
open borders is a radical irrational
idea that cannot be accepted contrary to
what you might hear from open borders
radicals we are not asking California
Oakland or anyone else to actually
effectively enforce immigration laws
although we would welcome the positive
assistance the majority of jurisdictions
in America provide to our federal
offices we would certainly like that but
I say just do incredible work every day
they're not backing down they're not
going to be deterred and we're not going
to stop enforcing the law and in Alabama
or California either now President Trump
Jeff Sessions and the federal government
they are simply standing up for the rule
of law now the radical left they're
putting criminal illegal immigrants
before the safety of American citizens
now all the Trump administration wants
to do is enforce federal immigration
laws that are already on the books it's
really that simple
we either in this country we have law in
order or we have chaos now let's say you
don't like the laws then change them
elect people that will change them but
if you break the laws on the books you
should suffer the consequences
now California's officials well they
don't have to help they just need to
stop interfering or in the case of this
Oakland mayor aiding and abetting
criminal illegal immigrants well a lot
more on that too
graceful story and potential crimes of
the mayor in just a second but what's
disturbing about all of this is that
officials in California they're now
risking your lives because they think
protecting criminal illegal immigrants
is good politics
they are literally willing to endanger
Americans by harboring people that have
no reason to be in this country because
they think it will win them a couple of
extra votes you have liberal politicians
like California Governor Jerry Brown
they don't want to debate the issues
because they know the facts and the
truth and the rule of law are not on
their side and that's why instead of
addressing why his state is shielding
criminal illegal immigrants well
Governor Brown instead he attacks Fox
News he accuses the federal government
of going to war really Jerry what's this
this is really unprecedented for the
chief law enforcement of the United
States to come out to California and act
more like Fox News than a law
enforcement officer this is a political
stunt it's more like Fox News and what's
going on in Washington and it's not
about the truth it's not about
protecting our state it's about dividing
America this is basically going to war
against the state of California the
engine of the American economy it's not
wise it's not right and it will not
stand
okay it's not right but we did invite
Governor Brown to come on the show
tonight but shockingly while he said no
now Governor Brown has no facts to back
up this argument so it's no surprise
that he's too gutless to come on the
program now liberals in California you
need to answer one simple fundamental
question how does America benefit from
criminal illegal immigrants staying in
the country if you don't see this as a
danger that is posed to every American
well I don't know how I can convince you
what is the upside what is the reward
why are you willing to risk and imperil
other people's lives these are criminal
aliens we're not talking about daca here
now people like the mayor of Oakland
Libby Schaaf they sure seem to think so
and that's why the mayor was tipping off
criminal illegal immigrants
about the ice raid late last month and
guess what happened as a result while
the acting head of ice says that about
800 criminal illegal immigrants were
able to avoid arrest is that what
Americans really want elected officials
to do to protect illegal immigrants that
are criminals now the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions blasted the Oakland mayor
earlier today let's take a look so
here's my message to mayor chef how dare
you how dare you needlessly endanger the
lives of our law enforcement officers to
promote a radical open borders agenda
what this mayor is doing is disgraceful
but despite the mayor's actions I still
was able to detain criminal illegal
immigrants look at the stats about the
Oakland area rate in spite of the
warnings 232 people arrested for
violating federal immigration laws now
of that 232 arrested a hundred and
eighty were either convicted criminals
had been issued the final order of
removal and didn't leave or had been
previously deported and then returned
again to the US illegally because we
have open borders 115 of the 232 had
prior felony convictions for sex abuse
weapons charges and assault now those
are the types of people that this
Oakland mayor is protecting now of
course Libby Schaaf is defiant defending
her lawless behavior but the Department
of Justice is now looking into a
possible obstruction of justice charge
against her for what she did now keep in
mind if California lawmakers if they
want to continue to obstruct federal
immigration officials from actually
doing their job then President Trump
should follow through on his threat to
pull ice agents from California you may
remember this we're getting no help from
the state of California I mean frankly
if I wanted to pull our people from
California you would have a crime less
like you've never seen in California all
I'd have to do is say ice and Border
Patrol let California alone you'd be
inundated and you would see crime like
nobody's ever seen crime in this country
and yet we get no help from the state of
California all right when it comes to
criminal
illegal immigrants the media the laughed
liberals they refuse to look at facts
and because of this they are complicit
in the harm that these people in the
future will cause to American citizens
now unlike the left and most members of
the media well we've actually been down
to the border over a dozen times we have
watched firsthand what is going on down
there I've been on horseback all-terrain
vehicles helicopters boats I've seen
drug warehouses tunnels I've seen it all
when President Trump says we need a wall
he's right and I don't mind a wall with
the door either in 2014 i sat in on a
border briefing with then Texas Governor
Rick Perry listen closely six hundred
and forty-two thousand criminal offenses
committed by illegal immigrants in the
state of Texas alone in only a seven
year period a serious problem
watch criminals have been responsible
about six hundred forty two thousand
offenses criminal offenses you look up
there in topless sexual assault there's
close to eight thousand victims six
hundred and forty two thousand crimes
two thousand in Texas alone yes over two
hundred thousand it's individuals their
criminal history reflected there was
David they were committed over six
hundred forty two thousand crimes that's
the cost six hundred and forty two
thousand crimes created in in impacting
the citizens of Texas in a seven year
period then there's all the statistics
that the liberal mainstream media always
conveniently ignore truth doesn't seem
to matter to them according to the
migration policy institute about eight
hundred and twenty thousand of the 11
million illegal immigrants in America
are convicted criminals eight hundred
and twenty thousand the US Sentencing
Commission has found that illegal
immigrants account for 13% of all non
immigration related federal sentences
for the fiscal year 2016
now this despite the fact that these
illegal immigrants they only make up
three point five percent of the
population three point five thirteen
percent and this is important that
number is only dealing with
federal sentences much higher if you
factor in convictions by state and local
governments now according to the latest
report from the Government
Accountability Office get this an
estimated 55,000 criminal illegal aliens
were in federal prison in the year 2010
in fiscal year 2017 ice deported over
two hundred and twenty six thousand
illegal immigrants and also in 2017 over
a hundred and twenty seven thousand of
those deported were previously convicted
of a crime and in 2010 the DOJ found
that 57% of immigration offenders
charged in US District Court had prior
felony convictions now the facts on
illegal immigrants are irrefutable and
that's why the left and the media never
talk about them you've never seen this
before
I'm guessing this is about protecting
you the American people it's that simple
all right we'll have more on this in a
minute now also breaking tonight we have
more evidence more proof that the FBI
lied to that FISA Court judge in the
original application and three
subsequent renewal applications to get a
warrant to spy on a member of the Trump
campaign remember in an election year
and according to a New Yorker report
former British spy Christopher Steele
who put together this phony dossier
filled with Russian lies and propaganda
he knew he knew he was being paid by
Hillary Clinton he knew he was being
paid by the DNC just months after he was
hired by fusion GPS now this is
significant because according to
congressman Adam shifts memo which
references the FISA application for the
warrant the FBI told the FISA judge that
Steele was never told about the
political motivations behind his work
also remember Steele hates Donald Trump
also so the FBI again flat-out lied and
what we can only assume here is that it
was an effort to make Steele more
credible as they were omitting evidence
to a FISA judge
now the FBI Fuzion GPS remember they
never bothered to verify corroborate the
fake news dossier which is mandated in
FISA law and by the way it's part of the
FBI
zone protocols then also the FISA
application was denied the first time
but then steal and the dossier was
brought in to put the request over the
top or to quote former Deputy Director
of the FBI Andrew McCabe remember he
testified without the dossier there
would never have even been a FISA
warrant application that's how important
that dossier was to getting the approval
of the FISA Court now this scandal is by
far the most massive abuse of federal
government power in the history of the
country and that's why a second special
counsel needs to be appointed like
yesterday and the month before to
investigate what is severe FISA abuses
alright also finally tonight new details
about how the FBI missed a critical
warning sign from the deranged Stoneman
Douglas high school shooter Nicholas
Cruz now Congressional Committee
Chairman trey Gowdy Bob Goodlatte they
issued a press release on key findings
from an FBI briefing on the parklands
shooting now its previously been
reported that in January of this year a
friend of the Cruz family called the FBI
tip line to report Cruz's disturbing
behavior well tonight we have new
information about how that FBI agent who
answered the call handled it and
according to Gowdy and good let's press
release after that call warning about
Cruz the person who took the call spoke
to a supervisor about what was said
their conversation was never documented
and at that time the FBI was able to
connect Cruz to a different September
call to the FBI tip line and that's
where Cruz made a threatening YouTube
comment about wanting to be a
professional school shooter now despite
that information the FBI never proceeded
ahead with an investigation the FBI
never told local authorities they never
told the field offices about this and as
we've been saying this entire tragedy
all of it could have been prevented but
there of course was a series of gigantic
bureaucratic failures now instead of
trying to fix this system correct those
mistakes we should secure the schools
like we secured those Hollywood actors
and actresses that were on the red
carpet
on Sunday well the left of media
predictably they continue to blame guns
all in an attempt to limit your
constitutional right to keep in to bear
arms